derek henry throws the touchdown pass
and congratulations derek henry you're
disqualified from today's draft we are
doing the most important
non-quarterbacks for conference
championship weekend but we're taking
derek henry out of that mix too because
he's clearly the most important on
quarterback and by virtue of what he did
last week he's also kind of a
quarterback so yeah anyone except the
quarterbacks and derek henry is fair
game in this draft of the most important
on quarterbacks chris i've got the
trivia question for you if you get it
right you get the first pick
mike and kyle shanahan are the only
father-son duo to each appear in a
conference championship game as head
coaches in nfl history there's only one
other father-son duo of coaches that
have playoff wins
who is that duo
oh man
father son duo that got playoff wins
i mean
i want to say wade and bum phillips but
i'm not
okay i wasn't sure if wade won a game or
not
wait he wasn't done yet he wasn't done
he was he may have screwed it up and
said i don't know some other father-son
button fred grant i don't know
bum and wade you get it right you get
the first pick well done okay all right
well that was uh yeah i i i wasn't sure
if wade won a playoff game as a head
coach or not but so i couldn't remember
there i almost choked that one off all
right um
i i i'm going with the smith brothers
the brothers from another mother okay
preston which one i'm going with both
they're synonymous here okay i'm going
with both i know i'm cheating but you'll
understand the point i'm making here
when i get done with it yeah i think
these two zadaria smith preston smith
they're vital if the packers want to
have any chance of winning this football
game because these guys are well-rounded
football players they're really good
against the run and they're gonna have
to be really good against the run this
week if they want to win this football
game added to the fact that you know
mike pettin uh and company they need to
pressure the quarterback with four they
can't be throwing up five and six guys
at the line of scrimmage for then
shanahan to have a play-action fake and
then nobody be at the second level and
depot samuel or george kittle are flying
down the middle of the field for a
50-yard gain so it's going to be
imperative not only for the smith
brothers to slow down the shanahan run
game the things they do on the edge
they're edge defenders they'll be
responsible for that in the run game but
to be able to really pressure the
quarterback and win their one-on-one
match-ups with staley and mcglinchey if
they can do that and be somewhat
dominant there of course uh i think
green bay has a chance to win this
football game
same team other side of the ball and
only one player at least one of us is
sticking to the rules with derek henry
off the board the next running back who
would have the most impact this weekend
aaron jones the green bay packers we saw
him do a little something early on
against the seahawks but then he got
shut down they're going to need more
from him yeah if they want to get past
the san francisco 49ers he can't go mia
in the second half you need to have
aaron jones in that run game especially
if the packers get any type of a lead
you got to grind it out he can't rely on
aaron rodgers doing magical things
throughout the entire game and if aaron
jones has an aaron jones game that's
going to make it
easier for the packers to do what seems
to be on paper a very difficult thing
yeah i think that's real mike i mean
from everything about it yeah last week
was great he jump started them right got
them going got them out to that 21-3
lead but it's like they they run out of
creative ways to give them the ball too
and once a team gets used to like oh
okay this is their bread and butter play
for the day it slows down like matt
lafleur company they need to like save
one or two creative runs for the second
half of the game too they got it so they
don't run out of tricks that way that's
one issue to me that always looks like
they they kind of stall out as the game
goes on because they run run out of
plays to schematically screw you over so
good pick by you i'm gonna go with like
a little bit of a captain obvious one
here but i'm going with tyree kill i do
think tyreek hill is really important
this weekend maybe more than most
because i think there's gonna be
instances one where the tennessee titans
like dean pease coming from new england
with mike vrabel they'll double travis
kelsey on certain situations because
they know hey it's third and five
mahomes loves to look at kelsey in those
situations uh and it's gonna leave
favorable matchups for tyree kill
one-on-one also mike you so i mean we
texted about this a lot during the game
last week like it's important too
like
hey if
what's the point of having patrick
mahomes and tyree kill and the team's
gonna play you man-to-man bump and run
in your face if you're not gonna take
some shots down the field so andy reid
and then they need to be aggressive with
throwing him the ball with deep shots
one to scare the defense off two there's
a good chance you'll get a big
completion three what we saw last week
is when they did it they got some big
pass interference calls too and you
can't forget about that you know that's
certainly a big aspect to what they do
but they can't get into the five and ten
yard passing game with people play a
man-to-man they can't let them get away
with that they got to scare them and use
their assets which is speed and a big
arm by mahomes and and tyree kill
all right i gotta flip it back over to
the nfc and i'm going with a 49er and
i'm torn between a couple of them but i
want to go with george kittle he didn't
practice yesterday with an ankle injury
you know he'll play and he's the heart
and soul of that team he is the guy that
gets them going and he was getting them
going last week even though they only
had three catches for 15 yards and and i
just feel like he personifies that
quality that with that spirit that can
lift the 49ers to the next level uh
whatever he's able to do offensively
whether it's three catches whether it's
six whether it's nine whether it's 12
he's and he relishes the duties of
blocking in the running game and you
know he'll play and he'll find a way to
be effective and he'll have two weeks to
heal up for the super bowl if they win
and i just think he's critical to making
that offense go the way that it needs to
against green bay yeah i agreed you know
you know his just his ability to block
in the run game the energy he brings to
that football team when he catches the
ball it energizes their own team the
crowd everything about it he's the fan
favorite out there right i mean you
could hear it when he runs out on the
field or does anything they love george
kittle and you get it he's a crazy sob
and he's fun to watch
um so uh yeah i'm with you there i think
if i'm gonna go here i'm gonna go with a
guy that we're not sure is gonna play
but i think it's important whether he
plays or doesn't that's chris jones i
think that'll be my last pick i mean
chris jones uh you know you could argue
is is the best defensive lineman in the
final four here uh as far as who's
playing this weekend and we don't know
if he's gonna play so that's huge to me
you know if he doesn't play that's one
that hey he's the biggest game wrecker
on the kansas city chiefs defense
there's nobody that causes more havoc on
their defense let alone like i've said
other than aaron donald there's no deal
with the tackle that causes more havoc
than this guy he's amazing in the pass
rush and he's amazing in the run game
too he messes up a whole lot of plays
and causes dysfunction on offensive
lines so if they can have him even at
less than a hundred percent it'll be a
big help to their football team he can
just be at like 80 to 90 percent it
helps them out having him out there
yeah i think it's gonna be critical if
they have any hope of shutting down
derek henry or at least maintaining him
in the range of 100 yards not 180 190 or
200. i have a feeling he's not going to
play but we'll see day to day with a
calf injury the thinking is he'll be
good to go for the super bowl if they
make it he didn't play on sunday against
the texans not that they needed him but
i think they really need him this
weekend against the titans all right
since you already broke the rules
i'm gonna break the rules too good you
went with the smith brothers on the
green bay packers defense i'm going with
the bee brothers brian balaga and david
baktiari or as you would call him david
the two tackles for the green bay
packers it is critical critical that
they slow down the edge rushers and it's
not going to be easy with d ford back
with nick bosa being nick boson we had
the clips earlier of how he was able to
get past the back up to brian balaga
when uh the packers in the 49ers played
back in week 12. they are going to need
to slow those guys down it is not going
to be an easy task but they are critical
to giving aaron rodgers enough time to
find somebody open to drop in that that
uh that uh
30-yard throw that we saw to jimmy
graham and the throws to devonta adams
he's not gonna have time to do it if
he's running for his life now he's got
mobility that kirk cousins doesn't but i
still don't think he's got the mobility
to run away from guys like d ford and
and nick boson on the edge so the
tackles need to do their job i i think
that's a strong pick i mean yeah you're
picking tackles i'm not mad at you for
picking two that's it it's like you're
you're picking one you already picked
two guys that's what i'm saying it's
like an important aspect you're talking
about the edge blockers i was taking the
edge defenders i'm saying i get it
you're right if they're huge for this
game they got no freaking chance of
winning this game unless those two can
block the two you mentioned bosa and d
ford
if they have to like go out of their way
constantly to help them out and max
protect and do all those things then
green bay's not going to win the game
they're just not you know they're what's
the you know again
bakutiari is arguably the best pass
protected left tackle in football he's
got to be on an island and do it himself
and that's the same with the bulldogs
what's what's
what's worse mike is i played with his
brother and i still don't know how to
say his last name it's like no i'm just
horrible i don't know what else to say
yes that's it i don't have anything else
to say to that okay okay uh you're a
jerk and see with this new radio clock
we've got plenty of time to fill but
let's save some time for the next
segment here's the quick recap of
today's draft most important on
quarterbacks
except for derek henry because we know
he's the most critical in either game
the smith brothers zadarius and preston
tyree kill chris jones those were
chris's picks my picks aaron jones
george kittle and the packers offensive
tackles brian bulaga and david
obacatiari as chris sims would say
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports